- I can't give you an answer.
I don't know and I don't care that much.
(lively music)
- If I had to say, it'd
say it has two holes.
A top hole, a bottom hole.
- A straw has one hole.
Just because it's a really long hole
doesn't mean there's two holes.
- Obviously this has one hole.
See, there's one here and
it goes all the way through
and on the other side, it's the same hole.
- Do you see two holes here?
I don't, I see one.
- It's zero holes, because it is a tube.
I think.
It's either zero holes
or two holes, right,
because I feel like a tube
has to have two holes, right,
because it's the two ends.
- I don't know.
I thought I knew, but I don't.
My gut was one, maybe it's two,
but then we're talking about
what the definition of a hole is.
And then what the
definition of a straw is.
- One, two.
It's a tube, but it has two holes.
- Okay, this has zero holes
and here's my argument for why.
It's a tube, there is a single opening
that goes all the way though.
But this straw has no holes right now.
- But then, it's like is it really a hole
because a hole is something
you dig in the ground, right.
You dig down and you build a hole
and it's in something solid.
I've just said the word
holes way too much.
- It tricks you because there's two ends,
so you think that there's two hole,
but it's really just one hole
with an in and out point.
I'm going one hole.
- Some people might thing
that this is two holes.
I understand that argument.
But if you're thinking about physics wise,
the way this tool also is meant to be used
is through suction, through one hole.
But then the liquid
has to come in one hole
and out the other into your mouth.
So potentially, it's two holes.
I was really aggressively
on the single hole train
the entire time and now
that I'm talking about it
I can't actually defend one hole,
because if there was
only one hole in a straw
you wouldn't be able to
suck anything through it.
Then it would just be a
vase.